you know I love love and listen to this
got some more news on another loved up
couple Gwen Stefani and Blake Shelton
are apparently taking things to the next
level sometime around the holidays the
proof it's in the music
it's official when and Blaker hit in the
recording studio together and
collaborating on a Christmas song you
make you feel like Christmas is the
title and Gwyn and Blake are Co riders
on the track a source tells et Gwen's
holiday album will drop this fall it
won't be the couple of nearly two years
first musical collaboration
their duet go ahead and break my heart
was included on Blake's solo album
release last year started this song and
wrote about half of it and sent it to
her and and she wrote the other half of
it you know and it was just kind of
something for for she and I I think to
help us feel better about what we were
going through and and my gosh you know
it ends up on my album he's so talented
and he becomes like such a different
world and but to make music together it
was it was just so shocking right now
only one Blake duet is planned for
Gwen's holiday album but it sounds like
these two really like working together I
learned a lot from him from go in when
it comes to songwriting already I mean
because she's so brutally honest in her
writing
[Applause]